aujourd'hui on va parler de etc
c'est vrai
bon aujourd'hui on va parler de
ok bon en fait vous vous souvenez
j'avais fait cette boutique sur le
sommeil sur la pilule du lendemain sur
les antibiotiques et sur plusieurs
autres et bah aujourd'hui on va faire 7
boules sur la
la simple encore ça
[Musique]
avant de commencer juste un petit mot
non cette vidéo est pas sponsorisée je
vais vous parler d'autre chose enfin bon
vous allez comprendre je vous en ai
parlé ici il y a pas très longtemps en
plus des vidéos habituelles de DTC je
vais à partir de maintenant vous faire
aussi des vidéos supplémentaires sur la
santé sexuelle et la santé mentale ça me
semble important tout le temps mais ça
me semble encore plus important par les
temps qui courent cette vidéo que vous
êtes en train de regarder en ce moment
c'est la toute première de cette série
mais j'imagine que vous voyez arriver
les problèmes avec une vidéo qui parle
de sexualité la démonétisation le
blacklistage etc si on ajoute à ça la
baisse du nombre de vues dont on déjà
parlé Cyprien ben de Nota Bene et plein
d'autres et dont je suis victime aussi
ça peut vite devenir compliqué quand
même donc évidemment je cherche des
partenariats je fais des demandes d'aide
pour pouvoir continuer à produire ce
genre de vidéo mais si vous voulez vous
pouvez aussi me filer un coup de main
sur Youtube salut c'est le Julien du
futur
attendez en même temps du futur ouais
bon bref je vous fais ce petit message
entre le moment où tourner la vidéo et
le moment où vous la regardez parce que
il y a une petite nouvelle je sais pas
si vous avez vu mais Youtube c'est
terminé pas de chance en sortant alors
par contre la bonne nouvelle c'est que
j'ai eu une aide du CNC donc déjà merci
à eux mais je cherche quand même une
alternative à utip pour vous permettre
de soutenir mon travail en général et
cette série de vidéos là en particulier
si vous voulez et si vous pouvez bien
sûr et si vous n'avez pas les moyens
c'est complètement possible bah vous
pouvez aussi vous abonner activer les
notifications et puis surtout faire
tourner les vidéos sur vos réseaux
sociaux ça amènera au moins à lutter
contre l'invisibilisation allez ce coup
là c'est parti pour cette bullshit sur
la sexualité je l'ai dit je m'en fous je
suis un ouf la sodomie rend incontinent
allez BIM dans le vif du sujet direct
bon ça c'est un truc qu'on croit depuis
un certain temps maintenant et il faut
bien reconnaître que les premières
études qui ont été menées sur le sujet
ils sont pour quelque chose parce que
les plus anciennes disaient clairement
que c'était le cas que la sodomie
provoquait une incontinence anale et
fécale alors que depuis
les études les plus récentes nuances un
peu le propos pour résumer mais on
pourra y revenir plus en détail dans une
vidéo dédiée il y a deux trucs qui
entrent en compte dans l'incontinence
qui nous intéresse ici la pression à
l'intérieur du canal et les sphincters
oui les Cinq Terres vous savez c'est
petits anneaux en muscle là qui font
qu'on est capable de se retenir les
études ont démontré que le sexe anal et
c'est important de dire le sexe anal
parce qu'en réalité ça englobe un
certain nombre de pratiques assez
différentes bah ça a des conséquences
sur les deux mais en pratique il y a
deux trucs qui sont importants à retenir
d'abord tout ça c'est très élastique les
sphincters etc donc ça finit toujours
par revenir à sa taille initiale mais à
deux conditions la première c'est qu'il
faut bien préparer tout ça avec douceur
et avec précaution donc il y a les
progressivement c'est à dire dilater la
zone petit à petit pas y aller comme ça
comme une brute et lubrifier un maximum
parce qu'il y a pas de lubrification
naturelle à cet endroit ça c'est pour le
côté pratique pour éviter d'abîmer ces
petits anneaux là et son petit ah il y a
un truc important pour ça comme pour
tout le reste en fait ça se passe mieux
quand on est détendu donc lâcher prise
confiance communication tout ça et puis
surtout on a le droit de faire machine
arrière si on sent que ça va pas le
faire ou si on a plus envie ça c'est la
première chose si on respecte bien tout
ça a priori pas de souci mais il y a
quand même un autre truc à savoir les
différentes études ont démontré que le
risque d'un continent augmente si la
préparation est pas suffisante comme on
vient de dire mais aussi avec la taille
de ce qui est introduit elle parle aussi
de pratique extrême
à base de points par exemple mais vous
vous doutez bien que tout ça n'est pas
hyper documenté donc bon en conclusion
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est la sodomie
c'est comme l'andouillette
si on aime ça c'est délicieux mais il
faut que ce soit bien préparé et si on
n'aime pas ça faut pas se forcer bien
sûr la masturbation rend sourd
sérieusement en 2023 bon ça on en a déjà
parlé je vous remets le lien vous irez
voir on saigne toujours après le premier
rapport alors ça aussi on en a déjà
parlé c'est une vieille croyance qui a
fait beaucoup de mal et qui en fait
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs une fausse
croyance autour de l'hymen c'est à dire
c'est cette petite membrane cette espèce
de replie de la muqueuse vaginale autour
de l'orifice du vagin on en a parlé dans
le dernier des testissimo donc je vous
remets le lien tu connais tu sais
comment ça se passe tac tac mais bon si
vous l'avez pas vu ou si vous avez
oublié bah je vais vous réexpliquer
quand même un peu cette membrane elle
peut boucher l'entrée du vagin mais pas
forcément parce qu'il y en a plein de
formes et de sortes différentes qui sont
disposés de façon différente il y a même
des gens qui n'ont pas du tout donc elle
peut se déchirer au moment de la
première pénétration et je dis bien
pénétration parce qu'un rapport sexuel
ça implique pas forcément une
pénétration vaginale elle peut se
déchirer mais pas forcément non plus
pour les raisons que je viens de donner
plus deux autres
parce qu'elle peut être plus ou moins
souple donc elle peut juste s'élargir un
peu et pas se déchirer et deux parce que
donc on a dit il y a des gens qui n'ont
pas du tout mais il y a aussi des
personnes dont l'hymène a déjà été
déchiré sans qui est pour autant de
rapports sexuel il y a plusieurs cas de
figure dans lesquels ça peut arriver
donc une bonne fois pour toute l'état de
l'hymen ça n'a rien à voir avec la
virginité et le saignement encore moins
surtout que même si l'hymen se déchire
bah ça saigne pas forcément parce qu'il
est assez peu vascularisé c'est à dire
qu'il peut y avoir très peu de vaisseaux
sanguins à l'intérieur ce qui fait que
même quand il se déchire ça saigne pas
du tout par contre ce qui peut arriver
c'est que le premier rapport bah ce soit
un peu à l'arrache dans des conditions
de confort et de tranquillité pas top
voire de façon un peu maladroite disons
donc ça peut entraîner des lésions au
niveau du vagin qui peuvent donner des
petits saignements parce qu'on n'a pas
pris assez le temps parce qu'on n'a pas
assez lubrifié parce qu'on a été trop
bourrin etc bon la première fois ça
finit toujours par arriver il y a pas
d'urgence il y a pas de raison de se
précipiter en vrai là je veux dire
autant que ça se passe bien
donc autant attendre de bien choisir le
bon endroit le bon moment le bon
partenaire etc en plus d'éviter les
saignements ça peut aussi éviter les
douleurs parce que ça il y a aucune
raison que ce soit systématique et ça
peut être évité par un petit peu de
douceur un peu d'écoute de l'autre moi
je dis ça après évidemment vous faites
ce que vous voulez mais en tout cas pour
clore le sujet on estime que 40 à 50%
des personnes ne saignent pas du tout
après leur premier rapport par
pénétration vaginale
le sexe oral fait sans risque alors non
on peut pas dire ça c'est pas le plus
risqué mais c'est pas sans risque ou
c'est pas son risque mais c'est pas le
plus risqué c'est comme vous voulez oui
là on parle d'Ister on parle d'infection
sexuellement transmissible on est bien
d'accord il y a un risque de choper ou
de transmettre une IST par le sexe oral
les rapports du coup génitaux comme on
dit mais là encore c'est bien de nuancer
un petit peu d'abord le risque est
beaucoup moins grand que pour un rapport
sexuel par pénétration vaginale ou anale
et puis ça dépend de quel ist on parle
de quelle pratique on parle et de quel
partenaire on parle pour prendre des
exemples concrets si on parle de VIH le
risque de transmission par cunnilingus
il est quasi nul par contre pendant une
fellation il y a un risque un très
faible mais il existe et il est plus
grand pour la personne qui pratique que
pour la personne qui reçoit surtout s'il
y a éjaculation dans la bouche donc pour
le VIH ces deux pratiques elles sont pas
à égalité par contre pour le papier
homavirus pour l'hépatite B pour
l'herpès par exemple bah là il y a un
risque dans les deux et c'est valable
aussi pour les anulingus donc en résumé
c'est du cas par cas ça dépend aussi de
l'état de santé et notamment de l'état
bucco-dentaire un petit tips chez vous
il faut éviter de se brosser les dents
ou de faire un bain de bouche juste
avant ou juste après parce que ça
risquerait être irrité les gencives et
de favoriser une contamination après il
y a aussi un risque de choper certaines
IST juste par contact avec la peau en
faisant des caresses par exemple on peut
aussi choper de l'herpès et dans
l'absolu même une hépatite B en
s'embrassant par exemple si on va plus
loin on peut aussi choper la grippe une
angine ou une mononucléose en son
brassant donc bon le truc à retenir
c'est que les risques ils existent et
que l'idée c'est de les faire diminuer
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit acceptable
c'est-à-dire jusqu'à ce qu'on soit prêt
à les accepter nous et nos partenaires
parce qu'on n'avait pas tout seul dans
cette histoire a priori donc faut en
parler alors pour faire diminuer ces
risques comment on fait bah déjà c'est
bien de se faire dépister régulièrement
attention ça ça protège pas dans
l'absolu mais c'est quand même important
de le faire pour savoir où on en est et
puis pour la fellation bah si on veut il
y a le préservatif externe il y en a des
noms lubrifiés pour pas que ça ait un
sale goût il y en a même des parfumés
on fait comme on aime et puis pour le
cuni ou la nul Angus bah il y a la digue
de Nantes à Montaigu tout ça un truc à
pas oublier il y a aussi des vaccins
entre le papillomavirus contre
l'hépatite B par exemple et pour le VIH
il y a aussi la prep mais ça ça mérite
qu'on en reparle dans une vidéo vraiment
dédiée on fera ça une autre fois en tout
cas il y a vraiment plein de moyens de
se protéger de diminuer les risques
après c'est à vous de voir les
partenaires ont toujours leur orgasme en
même temps oui alors bon c'est une
classe multiniveau ici donc il y a des
gens qui sont très au courant de ça
d'autres pas du tout mais on se moque
pas de ces petits camarades pas de ça
ici d'accord donc le coup de ce qu'on
appelle l'orgasme simultané qui est très
bien ça arrive c'est vrai mais c'est
rare en tout cas c'est très très loin
d'être le plus fréquent à part dans les
films en fait donc faut pas faire une
fixation là-dessus faut pas complexer si
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe pour
vous si chaque partenaire a un orgasme
c'est déjà bien ou en tout cas si chaque
personne qui peut en avoir un on a un
parce que tout le monde peut pas en
avoir mais ça on en reparlera un de ces
jours disons que si tout le monde est
satisfait on est bon le reste c'est du
cinéma
littéralement mais ça on va en parler
tout de suite plus c'est long plus c'est
bon là on parle de longueur de temps de
durée et bah figurez-vous qu'il y a
plusieurs études qui ont été menées sur
le sujet et notamment une qui détermine
que un rapport sexuel qui dure entre une
et deux minutes c'est jugé frustrant
deux trois à sept minutes c'est
suffisant entre 7 et 13 minutes c'est
satisfaisant et ensuite jusqu'à 30
minutes on dit que c'est trop long
au-delà de 30 minutes il y a plus de
mots apparemment
alors d'où ça vient cette idée que plus
c'est long plus c'est bon bah ça a
probablement toujours un peu existé du
coup c'est ce qui a toujours été décrit
dans les fictions dans tous les types de
fiction et notamment dans les films au
cinéma avec des rapports sexuels qui
durent des heures et qui se terminent
par un orgasme simultané on a déjà parlé
bon mais encore une fois c'est du cinéma
littéralement et puis bien sûr il y a le
porno en plus des corps et des
mensurations qui sont souvent hors
normes on peut souvent en regardant un
porno avoir l'impression qu'on est dans
une espèce d'épreuve sportive un peu
chelou une espèce de mélange de gym au
sol avec des figures imposées et de
course d'endurance genre un marathon un
marathon en fait sauf que attention la
vraie sexualité ça n'est pas une épreuve
sportive ni figure imposée ni timing
minimum obligatoire à respecter oubliez
pas que dans les films il y a le montage
déjà qui permet de tricher et puis on
parle de performance réalisée par des
professionnels quand même donc attention
globalement si je peux permettre de vous
donner un petit conseil n'essayez pas de
calquer votre sexualité sur le porno
essayez pas de la calquer sur quoi que
ce soit d'ailleurs on est toutes et tous
différents au niveau physique au niveau
psychologique au niveau de nos vécus au
niveau de nos envies etc une relation
sexuelle comme n'importe quel autre type
de relation ça se construit ça se
construit à deux de manière
personnalisée avec quelques règles
immuables comme le consentement la
confiance la communication etc pour ça
je vous renvoie à ma vidéo sur les vrais
aphrodisiaques alors ça parle pas de
diagra allez voir vous allez comprendre
ah il y a un autre truc important aussi
mais on va en parler dans le bullshitule
plus c'est long plus c'est bon on parle
plus de longueur de temps on parle de
longueur de
oui je vais pas vous refaire le topo sur
la taille moyenne du pénis au repos du
pénis en érection etc on en a déjà parlé
retourné jeter un coup d'oeil si vous
voulez je vais pas non plus vous dire
que la taille ça compte pas oui il y a
certains cas de figure où ça peut être
trop court trop étroit mais ça peut
aussi être trop long trop large etc donc
là encore ça dépend du ou de la
partenaire mais ça peut compter donc le
petit conseil que je me suis permis
juste avant ça vaut ici aussi parlez-en
tenter des trucs et essayer de trouver
quelque chose qui convient à tout le
monde mais surtout c'est important de se
rappeler d'un truc c'est que le pénis
c'est pas le point central d'un rapport
sexuel la sexualité c'est pas la place
de la Concorde et le pénis c'est pas
l'obélisque tu te métaphore que je vous
donne comme ça d'abord parce que le
pénis ok le pénis pourquoi pas mais
c'est pas indispensable il y a plein de
trucs à faire dans un rapport sexuel qui
n'impliquent à aucun moment à pénis un
rapport sexuel ça ne commence pas au
moment de l'érection et ça ne finit pas
au moment de l'éjaculation un rapport
sexuel c'est pas délimité par ça ça se
cantonne pas à la pénétration le pénis
c'est pas l'unité de mesure d'un rapport
sexuel il y a même des rapports sexuels
entre des personnes qui n'ont absolument
pas de pénis je vous avais sûrement déjà
entendu parler de ça non bon bref il y a
mille façons d'avoir un rapport sexuel
satisfaisant et il y en a plein qui
n'impliquent pas forcément à pénis voilà
DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui si il y
a des questions que vous vous posez s'il
y a d'autres trucs que vous voulez que
je débarque sur la sexualité n'hésitez
pas à m'envoyer un petit mail à question
DTC at gmail.com on se retrouve très
vite pour de nouvelles vidéos mais en
attendant vous savez ce que je vais vous
dire oui prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres mettez-vous bien et
surtout portez-vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]